it was
literally an attack on democracy
supporters of donald trump scuffling
with police inside the united states
capital
[Applause]
outside thousands besieging the building
even at a time when everything seems
remarkable in american politics
these are astonishing scenes
inside the chamber you can feel the
sense of panic
security personnel with guns drawn at
the windows
members of congress sheltering in place
on the floor
people taking what they could as
souvenirs
one person died after being shot by
police
another three after suffering what were
described as medical emergencies
[Applause]
the chaos and violence indicative of a
country riven
and a slice of the population unwilling
to accept defeat
they've been sent on their way by a
president almost two weeks to the moment
when he'll leave the white house for the
final time
continuing to make the case that he
didn't really lose at all
we're gonna walk down to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them what he called the evidence
has already been debunked but
as he was speaking his own vice
president was taking his place in
congress for what's usually a formality
of certifying his and trump's defeat
mike pence had by then already made it
clear he wouldn't bow to trump's
pressure
not long after the process was suspended
because of the violence outside
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
[Applause]
the calls for calm from the president
came long after the violence had started
even a belated video asking people to go
home contained
more disproved claims of fraud we had an
election
that was stolen from us it was a
landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now his tweets
along similar lines were removed by
twitter
his account locked hours after they ran
for cover
members of congress returned late into
the night to resume their work
to those who wreaked havoc in our
capital today
you did not win let's get back to work
this will be a stain on our country not
so easily washed away
the final terrible indeli
indelible legacy of the 45th president
of the united states undoubtedly our
worst
the anger and division in america has
never been quite so direct
two weeks out from what should be the
peaceful transition of power
what are the chances that all of this
ends with donald trump's presidency
greg milam sky news washington